20 أغسطس
على متن رحلة جوية إلى موسكو ،
التقط راكب حيتان أليكسي البحرية الفظيعة ،
أصيب
زعيم المعارضة الروسية
بالمرض فجأة
وهو يعرف بالضبط سبب خروجي من
هذا
الحمام ، وتم تسليمه إلى المضيفة
وقال له إنني قد أصبت بالتسمم.  سأموت
ثم أستلقي تحت قدميه
ولكي تموت ، كنت تعلم في تلك اللحظة
أنك تسمم ، نعم
التفكير السريع من الطيار ينقذ
حياته بدلاً من الطيران إلى موسكو الذي
لا يزال على بعد ثلاث ساعات ، تحولت الطائرة
إلى omsk اثنين  بعد أيام ، تم نقل البحرية
إلى برلين
حيث أعلنت الحكومة الألمانية أنه
قد تسمم بغاز الأعصاب
نافيتشالك ،
والآن يمكن أن يكشف تحقيق حصري
عن
مهمة سرية للغاية لتتبع البحرية
يشارك فيها خبراء في الأسلحة الكيماوية
يعملون لصالح فريق الأمن الفيدرالي
، الخلف الروسي للسوفييت.  كان
هذا المبنى غير الموصوف في
ضواحي موسكو المقر
الرئيسي للعملية
التي نبقى فيها في السيارة لأننا
لا نريد
جذب  انتباه ، لكن هذا المركب جزء
من
معهد علم الإجرام التابع
لجهاز الأمن الفيدرالي الروسي ، وخلف هذا
السياج ،
كان فريق النخبة من النشطاء
يتتبع
كل تحركات البحرية لأكثر من ثلاث سنوات ،
وقد فحص CNN مئات الصفحات من
سجلات الهاتف وبيانات الطيران
التي تكشف عن خلفيات
الاتصالات وسفر المجموعة
، تم الحصول على الوثائق من خلال منفذ الاستقصاء عبر الإنترنت
bellingcat الذي حدد قبل عامين
عملاء المخابرات العسكرية الروسية الذين
يُزعم أنهم أرسلوا إلى إنجلترا لتسميم
الجاسوس الروسي السابق
سيرجي
سكريبال ، تم تنشيط فريق السموم fsb في عام
فقط أيام  بعد أن أعلن نافالني أنه
سيرشح نفسه
للرئاسة في الانتخابات في العام المقبل
، قائد الفريق
ستانيسلاف ماكشكوف خبير في
الأسلحة الكيميائية
العديد من أعضاء الفريق هم أطباء لكن
لم يتم تجنيدهم لإنقاذ الأرواح ،
أردت فقط أن أعرض عليك بعض
الصور
هنا واسأل  إذا كنت تعرف
ما إذا كنت قد رأيت أيًا من الرجال  في
هذه الصور ،
لا ، أنت لا تعرف ، لا أتعرف على
أي منهم
، فسيتفاجأ عندما تعلم أن
بعض هؤلاء الرجال
ذهبوا معك أكثر من 30 رحلة
على مدار ثلاث سنوات وهو
أمر مرعب تمامًا.  أعرف ما إذا كانت كلمة
المرعب كلمة جيدة أعتقد أنها كلمة جيدة جدًا ،
نعم ، لكن
حسنًا ، أنا أفهم كيف يعمل النظام في
روسيا أفهم أن بوتين
يكرهني وأفهم أن هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين
يجلسون في القرم هم على
استعداد للقتل
هل يدّعي أن فلاديمير
بوتين كان على علم بهذا بالطبع
أنه لم يكن من الممكن أن يحدث بدون
أمر مباشر من بوتين
لأنه جيد في الأسابيع التي سبقت
تسميمه البحرية وأخذت زوجته يوليا إجازة قصيرة
إلى  منتجع في كالينينغراد
كشف تحقيقنا أن
فريق fsb تابع وفقًا لـ
bellingcat ، تم إيقاف الكاميرات الأمنية داخل الفندق
بشكل غامض أثناء تواجدهم
هناك.
شعرت بعدم الارتياح
لأنها التقطت
مقاطع فيديو وصورًا لرجال تعتقد أنهم
كانوا
يتابعونهم ، هذا الرجل أيضًا لا أتعرف عليها قالت بعد ساعات من مغادرة فريق السموم في fsb لكالينينغراد
يوليا فجأة شعرت بالمرض ، قالت حسنًا ،
أشعر بالسوء
حقًا هل تحتاج إلى سيارة إسعاف لا  هل لديك
شيء هل هو قلب
لا هو معدة لا هل هو رئيس لا
هل يمكنك وصفه لا
ثم اقتربنا من
المطعم وقالت جيدًا إنني أشعر بأنني
أسوأ في حياتي لم أشعر به من قبل
ولكن
للأسف وبالطبع لم أستطع  لا أقوم
بربط هذه النقاط
الآن ، أدرك الآن مدى
سوء استعادتها ليوليا ، لكن
يبدو أن وحدة
fsb لم تنته من القوات البحرية
في الأيام التي أعقبت بيانات الهاتف الخليوي كالينينغراد
التي أظهرت أن
العديد من كبار مسؤولي fsb كانوا على
اتصال منتظم
مع مختبر في هذا  مركب يطلق
عليه معهد الإشارات وقد أثبت cnn و
bellingcat
أنه شارك في
البحث
والتطوير في Navichalk في البحرية في منتصف أغسطس
وسافر فريقه  إلى سيبيريا يقوم
ما لا يقل عن خمسة أعضاء من وحدة fsb
بالرحلة نفسها
على رحلات مختلفة في تومسك نافالني
ويقيم زملاؤه
في فندق xander ، سافرنا
إلى مدينة سيبيريا لتتبع خطواته
في الليلة التي تعرض فيها للتسمم ، لذا فهذه هي
الغرفة
التي  كان أليكسي نافالني يقيم في المنزل
ويبدو أن غرفتي هنا
مجاورة تمامًا
وفقًا لـ navalny ، فقد ذهب إلى الفراش
حوالي منتصف الليل
بعد شرب كوكتيل مع
فريقه ، لم تكن وحدة السموم في fsb بعيدة
باستخدام ping من هاتف خلوي لدينا
تمكنت من وضع
أحد عملاء fsb في هذه المنطقة على
بعد بنايات فقط
من فندق sander في ليلة
19 آب (أغسطس)
الليلة التي شق فيها غاز الأعصاب navichalk
طريقه
إلى الغرفة 239. غادر البحرية الفندق في
وقت مبكر من صباح اليوم
التالي وصعد إلى موسكو  أصبح الطيران على ما
يرام بعد
ثلاث ساعات ، كان على وشك الموت
مرة أخرى في فريق تومسك نافالني يجمع بشكل محموم
أي دليل يمكنهم من غرفته بالفندق
بما في ذلك زجاجات المياه والشامبو
وفرشاة الأسنان  ومنشفة
كما فعلوا ، كان هناك ارتفاع في
الاتصالات
بين وحدة fsb ورؤسائهم إذا
كان من المتوقع أن يموت Navalny
في الرحلة التي كانوا يتدافعون
الآن للتعامل مع
وضع مختلف تمامًا
[موسيقى]
بعد الكثير من اللغة الروسية ذهابًا وإيابًا
تسمح السلطات بنقل نافالني
إلى برلين ،
ما لا يعرفونه هو أن العناصر التي تم
استردادها من غرفته في فندق تومسك كانت
أيضًا على
ظهر السفينة ، وقد تم اختبار بعضها لاحقًا لإصابتها بـ
navichuck مرة أخرى في موسكو.
هنا الآن في
منزل أحد فريق fsb
وسنذهب لنرى ما إذا كان لديه أي شيء يقوله لنا ،
ندخل مبنى سكني متهدم
في ضواحي موسكو
حيث يعيش أوليج تاياكين ،
اسمي كلاريسا وارد أنا  اعمل لدى CNN ،
هل يمكنني أن أطرح عليك سؤالين
للمراجعة هل كان فريقك هو من قام
بتسميم البحرية من فضلك
هل لديك أي تعليق لا يبدو
أنه يريد التحدث إلينا ،
أخبر علماء السموم CNN أن Navalny
محظوظ بشكل لا يصدق لأن يكون  على قيد الحياة
وأن النية كانت بلا
شك قتله ،
لذا قلت إنك تريد العودة إلى
روسيا وسأفعل أنك على دراية
بمخاطر العودة ،
نعم ، لكنني سياسي روسي
وحتى
عندما كنت  ليس فقط في المستشفى ، كنت
أتلقى علاجًا مكثفًا
وقلت علنًا أنني سأعود وسأعود لأنني
سياسي روسي أنا أنتمي إلى هذا
البلد وبالتأكيد أيها
الثاني خاصة الآن عندما
يتم اختراق هذه الجريمة بالفعل ،
أفهم أنني أفهم  العملية برمتها التي لن
أعطيها أبدًا لبوتين مثل هذه
الهدية لم
تثبت CNN أن فريق السموم fsb
كانوا في الواقع الأفراد الذين قاموا
بتسميم البحرية بالفعل ، لقد تواصلنا بالطبع
للحصول على تعليق من الكرملين وأيضًا
fsb
الذي أخبرنا أننا قد نكون قادرين  لتوقع
ردًا
في غضون تسعة أيام ، تواصلنا أيضًا مع
أعضاء الفريق كما رأيتم في تقريرنا ،
لكننا لم نسمع أي شيء حتى الآن ،
ولا ينبغي أن يكون مفاجئًا أن
المسؤولين الروس
لم يفتحوا أبوابهم بعد.  أي تحقيق جنائي
في تسمم أليكسي نافالني